một bữa cơm đủ nó.
Lời biết chỉ vì hỗ trợ tìm án của mỗi học sinh ở đây chỉ một trong nămu ngàn đồng.
Bể dựa các em chưa chính giang nâng trên YouTube của hai đủng bây
isp pra hoa hộp thình tuyến đắt cải tạo và sửa trở về banh chú mới,
lọc giái sẽ sẽ đầy đủ tiếp bị và an toàn hơn.
Hình nơi đây không chỉ là nơi nấu cơm, mà lại chốn sức tranh sẽ em cũng gào ở lại với lấp học,
với còn trữ để mỗi bữa cơm chở thành một lời độc viên.
Dạy địp biến, bọn tí tục đến hỗ trợ chưa mừng nọt tà bảo,
bây giờ đây là chêu, chức đầy các em ngò chỉ chưa quen trường không có sinh chơi
an toàn nhật đá nhật cạnh cây là bụr chơi.
Ngày các em đã có một khu vụ trời mới với đủ quay cầu trường,
tív gửi vang khắp sinh chường.
Không dừng lại ở đó, chuyến xét sóng nắng chuyển YouTube,
còn mang theo hơn 1 trăm phần qua khuyền học,
nhiều những hạt dống ấm thầm tiếp xúc cho các em trên hành trình chạp đến chí tất.
Chifall, về chuyến đi này, thành trị phó biết, điều khiến cô,
Tại tin mại sau trở đi là hình ảnh các em nhỏ ở các điểm dường.
Chức đây, tôi từng lĩnh mình đã đi nhiều thế nhiều,
nhưng đừng nghe như câu trận khí các con ở đây muốn được một lần trời sĩnh đủ như trong xác.
Hãy tập sĩ tất cả sản hơn là chạy hệ của mặt bè trong một xân trường của mẫu sắc.
Lối với nguồn người nổ đơn giản nhưng với các em học sinh ở đây vẫn là một điều sắc sị.
Đôi khi chi một giản biết nhỏ được cải tạo chín trang,
một xân trường khang trang từ chín giấc đơn giản,
lại có thể trở thành điểm tượng lượng lâu,
xuống tất em có thêm độc lực đến lắm,
lối dựa ở mơ đến chương buổi này.
Dưới mỗi mọi quần nhỏ là tình yêu thương tất lớn,
dự án sau nằm chình yêu thương,
được khởi dương từ năm nay nhìn không chăm mấy tư,
là một hành chín giải hơi của hai bộn bà y sprez,
với một tiêu kết lối nhá tấm lòng,
chi sẽ nhiều tụi tế và xeều hi bao.
Bình cạnh xương mạng phát triển các sải phát bất triển chào tình nghiệp,
hai bộn bà y sprez tiền giang,
chiến phát không chỉ là dau hăng,
mà còn có thể là dau nắng chình yêu thương đến đúng nơi đúng nơi.